previously on grave robbers so here's
the way I see him we're gonna put some
restrictions on this play I gotta beat
Ganon not do any shines so I'm not gonna
get any more hearts I'm not gonna get
any more stamina wheels that's another
thing too is I could easily sled first
shield surf and break a shield there's
one ferry down that was so quick get
away from him
oh no sorry what stop I think you I
think I'm good wait you could try stop
it up and fingers weapons oh he's stuck
all right fine now he's gonna get out of
there bunch you in real life you're
stabbing us I'm bleeding weapon
[Laughter]
okay oh he's horrible must crush me too
that'll do it third time you've got
intact hey everyone welcome back to
grave hoppers the show where we put
permadeath into every game I'm Mike
McCarty here with Rob and Lori hey you
did pretty well last episode you stocked
up on some health items you you lost a
few weapons but I don't know where so
you survived the entire episode and
Zelda this is what you this will be your
fourth a Zelda episode damn brave
hoppers if you're new to the show or if
you missed last week actually we've been
recording these beforehand we're not
doing alive but they are still going up
every Thursday we can do a lot cooler
stuff if we record them before the fact
but basic gist we try to survive an hour
in without dying in Zelda or any game
we're playing right now it's a Zelda and
then if we survive that hour we keep
playing that game next week
here's a list we have died in a bunch of
games already our list is dwindling we
we've already kind of added a few on to
the end that will announce at some point
we got a lot of good suggestions I'm
gonna pull those up at some point today
from commenters yeah but right now we're
in Zelda breath of the wild so far
you've survived what is it - our 53 2
hours and 54 minutes if you died today
we'll jump right into Metal Gear Solid 5
Ground zeroes if we have any time at all
left today before an hour from about now
so an hour from now if you are surviving
Zelda next week we'll keep playing Zelda
yeah we'll see a couple close calls last
time but salvos almost got lizalfos man
those guys suck so a lot of people were
the fairies save you a hundred as you
are you are for people who are catching
up you are not going doing shrines or
anything to up your stamina or your
health you are just pretty much
surviving or yes surviving on weapons
and armor and food right so we're quite
literally picking up where we left off
so
try to cook some stuff Oh fires going
now
so yeah chief coiler was the one that
recommended the fairies among some other
people but he was very I want to say
adamant about getting those fairies and
yep he responded thanks chief yep it did
save my life that because of electric
ease yeah insta killed okay so let's
let's do some cookin here so what's my
game plan well one thing we also realize
I have majora's mask I was what's
awesome stuff make some money see if I
can get some arrows from beetle now the
game plan is still for the most part the
same the end goal is to defeat Ganon we
talked about going to get the Hylian
Shield so I'm gonna go do that today
today baby
that being said I thought a lot about it
and I think I'm terrified of that Castle
Gans Castle yeah terrified these weapons
aren't gonna cut it a lot of these like
this this is garbage so what I'm
thinking I might do is make a pit stop
at a fairy fountain and I think they
getting at least maybe one or two Henoch
Sloot mmm-hmm
I think will be will be nice yeah
that'll help me out there is a lot of
good loot in the castle but I want to be
able to like move around comfortably at
the beginning boiler on YouTube also in
addition to that just saying get off
Arry he also said pro tip you can get
about twelve fairies from all the
fountains in Salta before they stop
spawning that's assuming you plan to
visit them all I suggest skipping in the
founding Gerudo desert because that's
really risky well the other two
shouldn't be hard to reach so I didn't
did not know about this tip so look at
this look at the durians what they're
doing here oh yeah plus eight health
yeah so I believe five will give me a
lot so I'm I'm probably gonna do that
sorry why'd you either in that oh oh so
those don't just like continually fade
you have to actually go damaged
yeah okay gotcha so these I mean I
should probably just do maybe just three
now no wish had more durians I'll do
four and then five see this doesn't even
that much like plus sixteen hearts yeah
man yeah yeah you just need weapons for
now for the most part you fight that big
stealth oh dude in the castle right is
that what you're talking about look guys
it's a style Knox whatever it's
basically a UNIX that's a skeleton he's
guarding the Hylian Shield so he will be
there kind of easy oh but I can't freeze
them with the stasis mm-hmm
he'll be difficult oh yeah because you
don't have that upgrade No so another
thing like I can't I won't bring this up
to you is that the champions tunic you
get from after meeting you go meet up
per uh the scientist that turned into a
girl yeah who gives you the chicest
light camera then I go back to Impa and
I get I get the champions armor so I I'm
I guess I'm bringing it to you like
should like I should probably do that
probably worth it yeah yeah so that's
what I was thinking
yeah right now you're just rocking the
what she could top everything else is
basic yeah oh yeah James Guerrera also
pointed that out on YouTube you get the
champions tunic from the memory quest
haha so that's DS in their mighty
bananas and mighty thistle Oh nope do
you have anything that will help mighty
fist will help for an stamina right
mighty fist and mighty bananas is attack
power okay I had some dragon parts that
do clutch but
so that's pretty good there that's not
much and I guess I'll put this a spice
think you're going anywhere cold
question possibly we'll call it there on
stuff I can do what's I'm pretty sure I
can sell god the framerate still yeah
pretty sure I can beat a lot I can sell
my Majora's Mask
there's the yeah we decided right few
people had decided that uh Eric green
who's a common sorry a constant viewer
for GameSpot saying keep Majora's Mask
off or moved a lot of attention we
eventually learned that in the last
episode yeah he also was asking a few
things a durian is not just a stinky
fruit but also an excellent bludgeoning
weapon why is that true or is even real
life I don't know no oh yeah in real
life and then he asked his majora's mask
Mike's favorite game I think
XCOM might have something to say about
that mean bucks thought that'd be a lot
more it's very cheap yeah Majora's Mask
is my favorite game of all time ex-con -
might be right - it's my team or it's my
favorite modern game because I did
mention that Majora's Mask my favorite
game yeah even I was I was talking about
last time how you could just get
Majora's Mask in a chest a random chest
is kind of odd can you sell it for 15
rupees it's the same amount as an old
shirt the hell is that
junk it's crap Beatles or there's a
sleazy salesman maybe I can buy some I
didn't I was hoping that would give me
more damn
probably go five more sorry this is
gonna be a little boring but we also got
another suggestion from Stephanie Nicole
she said if you're gonna get the Hylian
Shield next episode then you might as
well sneak your way into the armory and
get all the Royal Guards weapons instead
of finding the he Knox's yeah so she's
totally right but I I think that I'm
gonna need something to help me explore
that castle cuz again I got absolutely
diddly squat like these these are gonna
well the amount of health you have will
it even matter what you're wearing in
terms of all the champions tunic help
that much oh yeah you have more than it
well I guess but it'll help okay so I
did that let's go now to let's even get
this Phoenix stuff so I marked just
before weapons I marked Phoenix
locations okay I'm going to see if I can
pair glide onto him and take his stuff
yeah that was much easier than trying to
go up his hand yeah I did you're
supposed to be able to pull it off like
an elevator but nope yeah you have to
crouch to be silent really silent but in
order to climb on I think you have to
stand up first yeah very very confusing
it's probably simple just we didn't do
it right okay oh you so the red markers
hehehe NYX mm no that was this was just
an old marker oh yeah that's cool so
that's just gonna be pretty much always
you could mark it if you want yeah
[Music]
too far you just doing on your map can
you oh you're right you're right
purple purple oh you were too far he's
far closer you might just be able get
onto him from here
possibly stamina stamina I'm gonna run
out right near him and then wake him up
oh yeah so the other thing I could do is
get extra stamina by going to fairy
fountains and getting Endura carrots
okay
I'm cooking those so I could do that
here dog I did leader stable I don't
know what might be a stable no there's
no stable around there Puccini oh you
know what's here hmm
oh wow I really do know this game there
is a chest is it a DLC item no it's a I
think it's a phrenic bow there the
faster shooting one that's the sniper
one okay well under that slab yeah I
believe so
I saw you doctor rocks are annoying in
this
that really does suck when you're
conserving weapons travelers fear is not
that great
am i right great still not bad I mean I
think it's around here though right I
didn't even see the he knocks I didn't
see him either
IIS tomato cuz it's hard to tell when
your map is grayed out but
one of the feed 200 hello who so he's so
he's the highest level those are oil
weapons aren't they yeah they should be
clutch I could have made that from the
tower yeah what about that that column
over there is that too high for your
stamina right there yeah I think so it's
pretty high how's this thing but this
right here probably got a little bit
colder you might need this I don't think
I'm gonna need those and peppers dude it
might get boring but core exceeds would
be helpful to get your weapon inventory
up yeah I mean that's the thing about
Clorox you could do them on the way to
everything else for sure man
oh I feel weird not having the dirtbikes
keep thinking about the dirt bike
I took a lovehate ya like it like the
magic of this game was just always like
the first hundred hours I want to say
definitely glad it was DLC like after I
read a lot of the game it's cuz it just
totally ruins the idea of a horse so
cool hey I did I barely used horses I
just love it's like finding something
every ten feet distraction these are
kind of hard because I don't know where
you put it
oh this one you set to complete the
shape right these kind of things yeah
but this one is like a spiral eyes I
don't know where you put it I think I
just saw it I get what you're saying but
I think it's right in the middle there
oh you're totally pretty bad some of
these are super some of them you need to
see from like higher up right forgot how
many you had you were you almost had
enough for another I think you wonder
yeah I was one or two short for from a I
think was six from another weapon slot a
little bit I'll definitely be helpful
you're gonna break a bunch of them in
the castle if not all terrified of that
cosmo alright where's this oh sorry he
is writing the on the willy pads in the
water yeah oh he was yeah oh I'm so
sorry no he wasn't
are the are the like the darker colored
ones the harder ones yeah oh that's a
lot of good stuff it's a bow - thanks
yeah those are awesome that bow is dope
Oh another bow
no you just couldn't carry it oh yeah oh
if I drop it on him is he gonna know
just [ __ ] get out of there I'm
surprised the [ __ ] like that in this
game is like yeah let's get out of here
you never saw me so what are you doing
now let's think here now
now let's go let's go get that camera
stasis yeah you gotta go to what hottie
no go it for that yeah I do
alright so meaning probably the best way
oh I think it's in here I want to see
soccer so every time you go on stir
parts I keep thinking I wonder if you
have any if there's anything you could
buy that's worthwhile from that the
monster salesman yeah the thing of the
monster sales when though is I think
that's tied like a slayer quest I have
to like go find him he's always I
thought he always the first time is on
the eye of the skull lake the left yes
he is then after that he moves around I
don't know but isn't that the same as
Majora's Mask like that's all that's the
coolest stuff he has he doesn't really
have anything else oh like I skies is
for certain monsters yeah I guess so
like dude oh my god would that have just
killed you or that have been a fairy a
fairy right possibly yeah I just saw the
shadow I know I know I know
oh [ __ ] what the bomb Thanks
what were you saying this a friend
Franek phrenic whoa pretty sure it is
for the feathers and stuff yes
great goddamn this inventory yeah you
knocked core exceeds with the super good
again you'll just come across those by
happenstance though okay so this is
potato village so we'll go get our horse
a gallop and then what else um just did
a Phoenix I was gonna say we could farm
dragons so one of the cool things if you
get a if you get a a dragon's horn and
three mighty bananas and a money thistle
you get 30 minutes of max attack up you
know there's one spot where you could
farm but like that'll be boring he's
near the jungle right or he goes over
the jungle boy real a spring fair off so
I might as well get that tower
and going for almost 20 minutes just for
reference hmm we haven't already
mm-hmm that's been 20 minutes mm-hmm
Jesus a little less what at 15 hi
there's guardians come alive one of them
a couple dude there's that one field in
Northeast that's a bomb yeah kala yeah
there's a whole bunch of them well this
is that old defensive wall yeah got the
setting is so neat yeah like just to
imagine what kind of battle was here
like yeah this is one of those oh yeah
because there's a memory around here
right yes this is one of those places I
didn't even see until later later in the
game 200 hours in that's what sneeze
this is one of the ways you can go to
get to potato hear that in the tree
oh it's that those take a lot
so sick honestly like in my time at
GameSpot those first few months of this
game like like I will always remember it
was so [ __ ] cool
yeah like talk about what we found and
like we were seeing just seriously it
was like the most magical experience
yeah they're like playing for like 50
hours and hearing about something that
you had no idea existed yeah or more
than 50 like dicks I mean you do that
too all right battle cry oh you wanna go
you could take their meat ooh Oh get
away from him hit both him
yeah Double Trouble this guy's about to
swing
what's all get the hell out of here
Oh No yikes oh man
your horse is stupid
Oh No Oh
rocked okay this is jamoke coming in I'm
just gonna go there's a meet back there
I don't know how much you care about
that seam do that oh god but stop oh god
oh god
the situation you're putting this horse
into I know and I'm really afraid he's
gonna die and that's gonna be a problem
they come back you have to go to the
worst ferry think you gotta give them
coin - how do I get there I don't know I
don't need to go that Tower
I mean how cool how far are you from I'm
basically a hotel container about to be
this looks like it's going toward it
oh the marker is not the tower the
markers okay gotcha
Oh horses gonna be the death of me don't
worry about this guy knows whoa
that's interesting like the first time
he sees you he's like it might have been
but Stu although he's afraid of the dye
merchant is so sick what she wanted
probably walk to the Tower of her should
I say no right
the tower is not the tower the yeah I
might mium Agana shrine you know yeah
yeah use horses way more than me want
you to go hey
oh there's soldiers armor here that
could be clutch I don't have much money
a metal arm oh yeah
I wonder what I need for the stasis
upgrade that's pretty key forgot do you
it's not related to a shrine right no
you get it from okay
walk the rest of the way this horse
thing is not fun oh [ __ ] you don't have
to do that torch thing to you I'm just
thinking I might need to oh my god I
don't think that's worth the champions
tunic I hope it's not that
yeah you can't they can't make I mean I
know they can't make anything about that
power she's a cool character oh yeah
she's messing again
now God maybe this was a mistake
Simon liar
oh yeah she's like a grown woman hmm and
she's there her dog you read her diary
yeah snap it II snapped don't you dare
make us do that torch thing it where
it's gonna be
[Music]
is that even worth it like as opposed to
just getting this soldiers armor or
something the stasis is clutch for the
Phoenix here's the thing about the he
niché's this this the stall he next one
it's a locked door I can't leave if I
run out of weapons I don't know what I'm
gonna do other than die alright cuz I
because we already made the rule that I
can't warp out combat it'll take a long
time to get the stasis upgrade that
won't it or you just need like money you
need some things what is it what did
that supposed to be on her head it was a
battery know what that was
can you do in the rain
I thought you're gonna do it on bus stop
no please don't I don't think it'll take
that long
this is just this is honestly one of the
dark spots in this game and one of the
few parts yeah the doctor remember you
do it again for dr. Robbie in a cholera
and now one really saw because there's
like poke albums all over the place
there's the others that and they
intentionally because you have to run
you can't worry you know you can't can't
use many of your items a pair glide
wherever it is so like you have to kind
of walk around and there's yeah there's
a bunch of enemies and you have to like
walk around a huge Canyon I don't think
it'll go out actually not I think about
it yeah I can remember
I don't think rain affects people flame
I guess
just that noise I say go for the
soldiers Armour and then I don't have
any money sell some stuff in town how
much does a soldier timer let's go look
at it and there's a campfire there I can
like
that's probably right Karla's from a
bunch of Reddit - around alright let's
see what this price is like 150 it's
gonna be even the regular highly in
tunic would be good
I mean that's I should probably get a
helmet you know because I'm currently
not covering my head like dumb head
I could probably what what's the armor
on the High Line tunic three or two
three three even threes good we're we're
who's working here is it you just take
something mm-hmm okay probably get there
a lot you jelly all of them alright 160
was it for the helmet 180 all of them
like how everyone just like gonna take
whatever the hell you got crazy oh this
lizard tail oh sweet oh yeah I love
these is it severed even better yeah you
got enough for the helmet now mm-hmm
some pants would be nice you don't have
good pants don't have good pants
yeah what about the telescas head talons
well now I could I could mmm I feel like
I met that's that's reasonable right we
should go for the helmet I don't know
it's the same amount of armor as the
chest isn't it but I don't have anything
on my head Islam say yeah so like that's
what the net gain yeah I mean you don't
really have much on your legs either
yeah they will buy anything no no I want
you to have two of these frogs for four
rupees
[Music]
yeah you'd have to get the helmet
I'm close I could almost get the pants
too yeah yeah yeah alright beiongs to
sell any clothes you could sell I sold
them already
shields are using can't sell weapons all
right well the helmets you get start
yeah
remember halfway through this episode
okay should I should I try the let's try
it I just want to do it do what I want
to I want to get that other piece of
armor the champion student yeah yeah we
were always asking for suggestions for
other games to play
Adrienne on YouTube right here said I'd
like to suggest the new permadeath mode
and Ghost Recon wildlands oh yeah you
played that one together - that might be
interesting right now we're focusing on
the single-player stuff but I have been
playing Ghost Recon permanent mode it's
called ghost mode that's pretty fun
actually there's pretty tense people in
on the right difficulty that could be a
potential one down to the list for sure
okay I don't think you could sprint
right
folks and those like go out right I mean
oh they don't go out actually
oh I'll maybe I was thinking the other
one when the folk albums are all over
the place
if it rains - be good be really great
I still wonder why they had this section
just because so many people dislike it
like I mean I mean it's useful in
teaching you how the weather can just
completely screw you over
yeah for sure outside of that I don't
see much else much other reason to do
this I mean it's it's very Zelda in a
way you know like I want to say there
are you could you could look at this
it's not yeah I mean there's not usually
this tedious but there are definitely
tedious Zelda quest for sure mm-hmm
I love those little particle effects to
come on its face it's a beautiful
beautiful face that's now protected yeah
so sorry to clarify this will get you
the champions tunic more or less Oh cuz
you get the camera and you go back to
the info and sheet oh yeah and then it's
like oh yeah you can now use the camera
to take pictures right okay memories it
wasn't too bad no other ones wait well
the other one is annoying because the
bow cob ones again for a second oh I
like want to make sure I'm not putting
it away all right give it pinky
oh snap frickin localization is so
awesome this game yeah it's pretty funny
all right that's the camera now I can
take full selfies rune goo nice go back
to Kakariko right yeah fine these was
pretty fun I mean no funds are like it
did you what did you do them all yeah
yeah it took me like I would refused to
look up where to find them and it took
me a while to get a couple of them well
cuz you could talk to the painter guy
for his name at the stables
yes and he give tells you like hints on
where they are in addition to the photo
but still some of them like they were
tough yeah there's some that are in like
wide open field you have to find the
exact place yeah let's see if she
[Music]
oh those goggles on top of her head yeah
oh yeah with antenna in the middle
almost like a bow - yeah ancient
materials oh yeah like the cogs and the
ice is it's its guardian parch is why I
need that's to get the stasis right yeah
[ __ ] yeah all right in order to do that
you probably want ancient arrows so I
have to go to Robbie I guess I won't get
it then I don't need it
screw it but you can get the tunic yeah
I mean if you use the Dodge correctly I
think that's your best bet against the
Phoenix stone axe but not even though
because it's such a hard thing to dodge
the problem with the he niché's is that
you know it's week one is you're either
gonna kill him or you're gonna end this
season I know I think I have a heart
attack but the problem with is you shoot
in his eye and about half health
he starts covering his eye and I don't
know the workaround at that point can't
you start doing the dodge flurry or no
is there no dodge floor with a Enix no I
mean I've never done it he's so big
his moves also would crush me I don't
know I got some point I just got it like
something that was and just do it
yeah but like
give me that Impa give it I don't want
to talk yes how did you how did you hear
you have a telephone you need to get
past all those Guardians first what are
you gonna do just run oh no you go to
the dungeons through the back door
yeah be still Guardians oh I missed that
crap she didn't give it to me she said
she said she has something to give you
no I go back go back and talk to her she
said she had something to give to you
[Music]
okay oh and it's upstairs in the chest
right no time I should have read that I
think it's upstairs is it or in here
somewhere
yeah I think you're probably right cuz
what's her name her daughter whatever
not daughter but she's upstairs okay
I talked to her daughter Christ why did
I skip that so quickly
complete the first task of captured
memories I just do one well go go back
downstairs
maybe it's downstairs it's
yes it says in hmm I don't think I have
to do all of them though in order to get
it I remember that being case
maybe you just need to do that first one
nope oh you need to listen to this I
think I have to do a couple or some crap
you have to do one yeah it is you have
to capture one memory your first memory
alright then that's what it is okay this
would be probably the easiest one
[Music]
how we doing on time you have about 20
minutes left I mean it's you know I'm
not not extremely entertaining but I
don't know I just don't want to die Mike
I know you're prepping I want to be
Gannon so you got right now you are
you're going to get the champ it well
memory than champions technical after
that you're gonna stock up on more
ferries before you do that I can get
this Lake right here
there's another suggestion from Caronia
say he said he or she said put hitman on
that list that would also be a good one
buddy funny that game is very good to
stream and very panic-inducing play in
general yeah yeah did you get found out
terrifying did you play a lot how's that
game not a lot but yeah I played enough
of it to play it here
remember I'm that rock right there yeah
it's like just past it it's about the
great nice hit recall if you skip this
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
that Dueling Peaks mm-hmm you saw that
Easter egg and dead cells right no there
is a Dueling peaks painting and dead
cells yeah did you know of all those
Easter eggs you know I mean I knew there
was some I didn't know I was doing yeah
piecing like a guardian
am i doing there's the math Becca to
Kakariko so that time to do something I
mean like what would you want after that
you want to go try to fight the he
knocks for the end of the episode that's
gonna take a while just because of his
health getting there we could make that
way you could go fight him and then oh I
see getting there - I was gonna say cuz
fighting him we could go past an hour as
long as you're still fighting him he
wanted to you got like 15 minutes left
now until an hour I could go to I could
get to the castle and then we could stop
there I could like my - I'm actually
near there so it's set up next week I
want to do this real quick oh crap crap
crap
great
looks purple about 50 mm-hmm that's good
could be some good pants I could get
those pants yeah well you're getting
that you're about to get the champion
tunic right now yeah to explain I'm
doing direct that's a wheel did she give
you pants - the champion - nickers it's
just the champions there is no champions
give it give it
nice got one extra play of armor
later you're like as bad as but stall
yeah this is better
yeah moving on up in the world yeah okay
um pants yeah and then I'll get all
Castle and then I'll get a shrine to the
castle yeah will used to fight any
Guardians or no no if you do it right
you won't have time I'd I'm not going to
fight Guardians I don't think I'm just
gonna run from them okay I'll tell you
what
yes this will be a good ending is there
is a shrine inside the castle yeah dudes
to get it to come up from the ground or
ever light a torch
you kind of do that would be that'll be
a good ending that would make next
episode uh pretty eventful right away
you'll just be able to work right in
there I mean yeah I'll get to the shrine
and pause there
even the soldiers pants yeah and that
should be this is a pretty good fit yeah
yes please thank you when I can sell
these dumb pants singers wearing like
your bottom half is hockey has what is
she doing you can take this piece of
[ __ ]
goodbye [ __ ] mess of an outfit
it's tough Laura yeah let's get to the
Casal oh god I'm nervous
yeah I can't believe that Majora's Mask
was 15 bucks I was like all week thing
I'm like that's gonna be easily 300
bucks they just don't want people to
cheese it like once you have the DLC you
could just immediately get three sure I
mean yeah within the world it doesn't
make that much sense
like maybe beetle just doesn't
understand how powerful it is or
whatever [ __ ] idiot know how parts a
castle for me you know just jump on my
horse it's about to get real oh you know
we'll get a store if you can write did I
need one more
you know I don't really care just give
me a slob [ __ ] it's gonna be six is it
six for a weapon oh well alright there
you go Mike nice all right so you guys
do open flies now sweet god I can't
stand but stall go get I'm a dumb
equestrian you know what he is a dumbass
horse I've had great horses in the past
he's probably the dumbest horse we have
the name suits him got my face we're
doing this version of link is an [ __ ]
his name's but stall you can't miss him
it's got a Rudolph nose he's I don't
know he's an idiot go get him find him
anything that took that should be dumped
on ugly carrots I know right oh hell
yeah I'll save that cook you give you a
little hell MA
Oh little better I call dough I like
that
all right okay the worst part about this
what stall we don't have much of a bond
no he's gonna pant he's gonna freak out
he's gonna panic I got confidence in you
already what OH
up top yeah infiltrate stealthily what's
the earliest you've ever gone to Ganon's
Castle This Is It this is for sure it
even just been in I mean three hearts
yeah actually is it worth eating another
thing to have more hearts right now well
you got your fairies yeah I'm actually
fairly well stocked I just don't want to
run out of weapons we shall find more
you'll find those royal weapon he's in
there I also have that attack up to that
[ __ ] Holly
the
up under your hearts what would the stat
boost
yeah well it's like oh you head up right
I haven't eaten oh okay how do I have
those actually two times three which is
pretty good
but hours of [ __ ] is it covered in that
stuff it's cut no it's got like Guardian
turret yeah especially that Rivoli's go
real real hairy this could be this could
be your finest moment or it could be the
end of all right just reminder oh you
die
we played Metal Gear Solid if you
succeed we play Zelda next week all the
airborne guardian okay all right well
let's party
line one Oh what's doll is just you do
well
Misha I could go get em you're already
come this far okay I just keep going
that yeah and get the one let's fall but
stall it's been real dude it could be
the last time we see you you know
oh you go down that well well
[Music]
whoa easy there tiger
[Laughter]
yeah I've been so annoying there's gonna
be like a sapphire or some crap oh nice
does your first non-regular air okay the
hell is this guy's jamoke what's on that
alright I'll go up there it's through
that door right so I'm gonna go
underground yeah it's like a minecart
crap wow you don't really take much
damage do
fine take it there you go okay guys hit
you should I do it this guy probably
sneak attack them
those octorok staring at you wherever
they are she ball in calling noise how
can I get oh they can swim
yeah hazel is elbows how do we get to
that jumping jump from here and glide
I'll go up there where's the dungeon is
this even worth it I don't know what's
in there yeah I think so what what's the
danger did that yeah good thing I keep
nailing it on guesses well no you're
right oh you're right that's a watch
that's the best we have so far okay so
it's this way over here
oh yeah just swim or cry OSIS yeah
oh boy
Jana Gana Gannon how about that smells
so bad yeah you just hear him farting
from anywhere I roll it's got to be like
that's gotta have like some kind of
sulfuric it probably smells like eggs
yeah rotten eggs yeah
you can climb this but if he died by
drowning like that so it wouldn't count
I initially thought that as well but
it'll just respawn you're on the shore
it's not a game over screen yeah I'll
lose a heart okay
oh I thought that was your dart I know
that was like wait thirty I messed up
try to remember where
[Music]
the Shriners
Oh
yeah
oh that's how you do these I know right
it took me so long
no no III stasis them and then hit them
and then jump on exactly that's what I
did for later baseline kicking in that's
in here you gotta fight some lizalfos to
get this shrine don't you like a bunch
of them shock arrow dudes in here too
speaking of eggs already drowning that
okay so this is gonna spit me out in the
there's two ways I think I can go
[Music]
[Music]
should I put this on
is that better
I'm just quieter oh yeah who are you
sneaking by right now let me see if I
can eat by all these guys all right so
there's okay okay
where is the shrine it's remember Dan
it's in here yeah bottom left there so I
need to go oh my god I don't think you
can just get to go outside first and
then in out onto that Lake
should I go back outside and then keep
going
so the Hylian Shield is this way yeah
you try for that should I just try for
it I mean it's either you're gonna
either get it or lose yeah I guess so no
I'm gonna get more weapons this is not
enough weapons like this is the only
there's a bunch of good [ __ ] around here
okay
that's try it would help though cuz
you're at like in your past an hour now
technically oh I am mm-hmm oh it's over
alright I'll see if I kick his ass
I can stasis him
[Music]
okay let's just do this
I'm so scared
what's your you have two more fairies
yeah I feel like I'm just committing
suicide right now that's what it feels
like so it looks like ah no you got it
he that they messed him up
nice no he's not he's got no what what
ugly things nice
yeah yeah yeah I gotta oh man my heart
what better than I thought you lost a
fairy but we're going to it's I'm having
one left now too
[Music]
oh I have to do this
should be
[Music]
there's a less often okay
[Music]
what did I do
I know
is up here okay so now we're looking
like okay let's find the shrine say we
can still get it okay so the shrine is
again
so we I'm facing this way it's to my
right so I could run outside
I love the music changing yeah I think
this is gonna be good
okay put this down there okay cool make
sure I got you got a spear the halberd
that was good yeah sword pretty well as
well prep that he can be for
[Music]
oh that one yeah there was one behind
the castle I think it's on the other
side
yep cool this is it that's quicker than
I thought he'd have to fight a couple of
oh well they're on the docks or no if
you had one of them bingo later
[Music]
what do you do for is it a puzzle or a
kilt a stuffing some with fire oh yeah
that's why the flame blade is that gonna
track them probably do a Hardy
ooh that's good I can get temporary
hearts a little big hearty tones are
good too that's good that's good
what it was a guy up here but thought so
[Music]
yeah during Sid frickin wild berry oh
nice a lot of stuff recently yeah this
is good
there's a lot of good stuff here
now you got all three well one I Sara
but let your arrow and fire than shoot
that yeah
yeah yeah
all right now you got the fast travel
are you gonna leave the castle next time
or what I mean I can you got a lot of
stuff to sell yeah all right we'll call
it there yeah
all right let's job prepped a lot Thanks
yeah little boring an apology worth it's
worth the next stuff look we got this
now yeah got a good weapons a lot of
stuff to sell you could get the soldiers
torso if you wanted to pretty good with
this I feel like yeah there's no set
there's no set bonus for the shoulders
home it's so like just like this yeah I
mean the fit looks dumb but you got a
lot of our elemental arrows cool yeah
well as always we'll be back next
Thursday thank you for the suggestion
caronia say and let me see who's the
other suggestion quick cronies say an
Adrian thank you so much for the Ghost
Recon wildlands and hitman suggestions
yeah we are always kind of adding to the
list because we died a lot in the
earlier games so we will be back next
Thursday as always with great hoppers
Rob is gonna maybe commence his assault
on Ganon maybe I think definitely
first things first like we're in a good
place now I think yeah I'm gonna get
that shield let me get the Hylian Shield
and then maybe maybe take a breather and
then I don't know maybe that same
episode maybe another one after that
cool seems like it could be a two-parter
awesome either yeah the way I see it is
like two more episodes ish either I die
or I win sweet sweet all right well
thanks everybody for joining as always
we would back we will be back next
Thursday with more grave hoppers see you
then thanks guys
you